قال الرئيس الفرنسيه مانويل ماكرون
اوكرانيا تواجه تحديا جديد يتمثلوا في
استهداف بناها التحتيه من قبل الجيش
الروسي اضاف ماكرون في القمه الثنائيه
الفرنسيه الاوكرانيه ان المؤتمر وضع اليه
لتنسيق المساعدات المقدمه للاوكرانيين
وضمان ايه صالحها بشكل افضل
تواجه اوكرانيا والجهود العسكريه
والمساعدات التي نقدمها لها تحديدا وفي
الواقع بعد تكبر الروس خسائر ميدانيه في
اوكرانيا بداوا باستهداف البنا التحتيه
المدنيه واغرق الاوكرانيين في الظلام
وتركوهم في مواجهه البرد اردنا ان نضع
اليه لتنسيق المساعدات الطارئه وايصالها
بطريقه افضل وانا هنا اشكرك كل ما تحرك
لدعم الرئيس زينكي لقد نجحنا بفضل مؤتمرنا
اليوم في التضامن مع الشعب الاوكراني